super intelligence just got valued at $5
billion or should I say safe super
intelligence led by none other than the
reclusive Ilia satova just got valued at
$5 billion with this detail free tweet
in just the last few hours and today we
also got more news of Gemini 2 grock 3
and not just one but two new
$125 billion data centers but all this
new seem so desperate right but there is
one theme through it all which is
computing power even to the point of
making data centers in space we as a
species are making a giant bet that
scaling up language models will unlock
true artificial intelligence if the
scaling hypothesis Believers are right
it's coming soon if they're wrong this
could all be viewed as the biggest waste
of resources in human history but let's
start with the news from just a couple
of hours ago that Ilia SATA has raised 1
billion at a $5 billion valuation for
his startup safe super intelligence
there he is by the way in the middle
he's definitely still alive and working
on AI if you haven't heard of safe super
intelligence don't worry it's actually
only 3 months old but as mentioned
earlier valued at $5 billion
if only my 3-month-old side hustles got
valued at $5 billion the world would be
a happy place but no more seriously what
will those $1 billion in funds be used
for well it's that key theme you'll see
throughout this video and probably
throughout the next 5 years the funds
will be used to acquire computing power
Ilia s by the way sent a link to this
Reuters article so we can pretty much
trust its spoton with its details the
Salient thing though about the company
safe superintelligence is just how
little detail they're giving out about
what they're working on essentially
though the key pitch is this give us a
couple of years and then we're going to
attempt in one shot to bring you super
intelligence by the way they're going to
do that with a team that's currently
just 10 employees strong but before you
dismiss them immediately they are backed
by some Heavy Hitters like Sequoia
capital and Daniel gross who is a
co-founder up to this point though Ilia
SATA who is clearly the key person in
this Venture hasn't given any real
detail about his approach but he did
sprinkle some hints into this article
satova said that he will approach
scaling in a different way to his former
employer which would be open Ai and he
said everyone just says scaling
hypothesis everyone neglects to ask what
are we scaling but he went on some
people can work really long hours and
they'll just go down the same path
faster it's not so much our style but if
you do something different then it
becomes possible for for you to do
something special before people get
completely carried away though I do want
to add a little bit of context to some
of the claims that satsa has made before
he co-led the super alignment team at
openai which just over a year ago set
themselves the deadline of aligning or
making safe super intelligence within 4
years now I'm not against crazy ambition
and Alignment is important but what
actual progress has been made in that
year and a bit yes I have read those
blog posts put out by the former members
of the team but it doesn't strike me as
being a quarter of the way to aligning a
super Intelligence on the grounded to
fancyful scale it is definitely leaning
toward the latter now naturally those
weren't the only grandiose Visions
announced in the last 48 hours here is
musk 2 days ago claiming to have the
most powerful AI training system in the
world he mentions it soon having around
200,000 h100 equivalents which are the
gpus that go into training larg language
models now your first thoughts might be
that that's either an idle boast or that
it's not really the computing power that
matters it's how you use it but I do
give comments like that and this one
from July more Credence because of the
capabilities of grock 2 grock 2 the
Frontier Model produced by musk's X AI
team is genuinely a GPT 4 level
competitor so it's worth paying
attention at least to when he says that
they are going to train the most
powerful AI by every metric by December
of this year and I will give one further
hint that that claim shouldn't be
immediately dismissed and that's from
this report yesterday in the information
now first it did caveat that that
100,000 chip cluster known as Colossus
isn't fully operational apparently fewer
than half of those chips are currently
in operation largely because of
constraints involving power or
networking gear and more about power
constraints in a moment but according to
the information open AI CEO Sam Alman
has told some Microsoft Executives that
he is concerned that mus X aai could
soon have more access to computing power
than open aai does and remember open aai
has access to the Beth Microsoft's
compute power it's at this point though
that you might be starting to wonder
something is it all just about computing
power isn't there supposed to be some
secret Source at open aai or Google is
it really just about raw computing power
can we buy our way to Super intelligence
well it's not for want of trying there
have been plenty of teams that have
tried to build their own Foundation
models only to realize that the key
ingredient is scale computing power
character AI even built up a loyal fan
base and had some stars of the industry
but couldn't make their own Foundation
models work you may also recall efforts
by Adept Ai and inflection which
produced the pi chatbot the key person
Personnel from those teams were snapped
up by the likes of Google and Microsoft
in short people are trying things as
alternatives to Brute Force scaling but
not that much is working currently sure
you can eek out compute efficiencies and
optimizations like GPT 40 the Orca
series of models and the five family of
models but nothing beats scaling and
that might be why companies are betting
everything on colossal new data centers
we're talking levels of in investment at
the scale that could fund the research
to cure entire diseases or perhaps fund
the national budgets of mediumsized
countries and you might have thought
from the title of this video that
there's a singular 125 billion
supercomputer but there's actually two
being planned I should of course add the
caveat that it's according to the
information via officials that would
know about such Investments namely the
source is the commissioner of Commerce
Josh tigan who said that two separate
companies approached him and the
governor of North Dakota about building
Mega AI data centers these would
initially consume around 500 megaw to 1
gwatt of Power with plans to scale up to
5 or 10 gaw of power over several years
those numbers of course to most of you
will be complete gobbley so for context
here is an excellent diagram from epoc
AI 5 gaw of power allocated to a single
training run would put the Power
constraint just above this line here now
given that it's expected that these
other constraints would kick in at
higher levels that would give us just
over 10,000 times more compute available
compared to that which was used for
training GPT 4 now given the broad
approximate Deltas between generations
of gpts that would be the equivalent of
a GPT 6 training run now yes I know that
there are quote leaks like this one
showing that GPT 5 might have between
three and 5 trillion parameters but my
adage for such leaks is don't trust and
verify and also the number of parameters
that goes into a model or the number of
tweakable knobs if you like doesn't tell
you automatically how much compute is
used to train the model data is also a
massive Factor there chinchilla scaling
laws have long since been left behind
and we are massively ramping up the
amount of data for a given number of
parameters but before we all get too
long in the numbers what am I actually
saying here I'm saying that with the
amount of money that's being spent and
the amount of power that's being
provisioned people are factoring in
models up to the scale of something like
GPT 6 by the way if you're skeptical
that any progress has been made compare
the performance of the original chat GPT
in November of 2022 with Claude 3.5
Sonet it's pretty night and day Claude
5.5 Sonic would be quite interesting to
to behold now just to emphasize how much
this scaling is a bet rather than a
certainty in terms of the outcome it
will produce here again is Mark
Zuckerberg it's it's one of the
trickiest things in the world to plan
around is when you have an exponential
curve how long does it keep going for
yeah and um I think it's likely enough
that it will keep going that it is worth
investing the um tens or you know 100
billion plus in building the
infrastructure to assume if that kind of
keeps going you're going to get some
really amazing things that are just
going to make amazing products but I
don't think anyone in the industry can
really tell you that it will continue
scaling at that rate for sure now you
may have noticed that I've barely
mentioned open AI successor language
models and new verifier approaches those
approaches previously labeled qar or
strawberry throw in a bit of an xfactor
over the coming months according to this
article from again the information
openai want to launch strawberry which
was previously called qar and check out
my video on that for what I think that
might be they want to launch that within
chat PT as soon as this fall
interestingly the only hint they gave of
its capabilities was that it could solve
a New York Times connections word puzzle
now since I read this article I have
been trying plenty of those New York
Times connections puzzles you've got to
create four groups of four words that
form a kind of logical set here though
is the interesting part if you feeding
the these puzzles to GPC 40 as text or
as an image it usually can get one or
two sets of four words but then what
will happen is it'll get stuck and even
if you prompt it to try different
Arrangements of the remaining words
it'll still predict the same things
again and again so at the very least
open AI must have pioneered a method to
get language models out of their local
Minima to get them to try different
things instead of getting stuck in a rut
how that plays out though in terms of
true reasoning capability I'm going to
wait to test it on SIMPLE bench to find
out speaking of experiments though let
me quickly introduce you to weave from
the legendary weights and biases the
sponsors of this video proper
evaluations of language models are
absolutely crucial as is clearly
visualizing the differences between them
you'd also ideally want your toolkit to
be light weight so you could confidently
and quickly iterate on your llm
applications so in addition to their
free courses and guides do check out
weave using the link you can see on
screen which will also of course be in
the description now though for what some
of you have been waiting for the news we
got yesterday that one startup is
attempting to build data centers in
space such is the need for Reliable
energy to power these data centers we
are resorting to putting the data
centers into space this company Lumen
orbit is a y combinator startup and they
are aiming 4 gwatt scale their promo
video even mentions a possible 5 gwatt
data center which again if dedicated to
pre-training would allow a GPT 6 style
model but I must add in a quick caveat
before we all go wild about data centers
in space things like this have been
tried before Microsoft tried to build
data centers underwater the idea was
that the C could help cool the data
center and save on costs and even though
it was described as largely a success
apparently it didn't make sense from an
operational or practical perspective the
cost of Maintenance among other things
was simply prohibitive now I don't know
about you but it strikes me that the
cost of maintaining things in space
might be even more but as you may have
already deduced that's not exactly going
to stop us reaching GPT 6 scale models
why not well we do have the option of
geographically Distributing the
computers used to train the models in
fact according to some sources Microsoft
found they more or less had to do that
apparently one Microsoft engineer on a
GPT 6 training cluster project was asked
why not just collocate the cluster in
one region well they tried that he said
but we can't put more than 100,000 h100s
that's roughly the size of that Colossus
project that we heard earlier from Elon
Musk in a single state without bringing
down the power grid as we saw from that
Epoch analysis it's the power that's the
constraining factor and also possibly
water but more on that in a future video
but if we distribute the training then
the Clusters don't all have to be in the
same place so it reduces that local
power drain and that approach of
distributed training to cut a long story
short is where we seem to be heading
according to a report out just the day
from semi analysis Google open Ai and
anthropic are already executing plans to
expand their large model training from
one site to multiple data center
campuses and we already know by the way
that Gemini Ultra 1.0 was trained across
multiple data centers so it can be done
and before we get to more details on
that there was this Hidden Gem in the
third paragraph again this article was
from today and it said Google's existing
models lag behind open AI an anthropic
because they are still catching up in
terms of synthetic data reinforcement
learning and model architecture but the
impending release of Gemini 2 will
change this semi analysis is a pretty
reliable source so that's an interesting
comment it seems like we will get Gemini
2 and Gro 3 within a few months and as
we heard earlier the strawberry system
from open aai in roughly the same time
frame we will probably have to wait till
next year for open ai's next Flagship
though which is code named Orion but
just for a moment I want you to forget
all the names and the fruit and focus on
one key detail if the key ingredients to
the performance of language models is
their scale we should find out that fact
by the end of this year or to put it
another way if scaling doesn't work up
to the levels of grock 3 and Gemini 2
then what else will if the data centers
are getting to the kind of scale where
we need satellite pictures to assess how
big they are and that doesn't produce
true artificial intelligence then well
do we have to rely on Ilia satova
obviously I'm being cheeky but it's
priced into the value I think of many of
these companies just the possibility at
least that scaling will yield super
intelligence so if it doesn't you could
expect a reflection of that in the form
of a bubble bursting just quickly I
can't resist pointing out that if you're
in America then the fact that models
will be increasingly interconnected
across that continent will lead to a
kind of interesting philosophical moment
Microsoft will quite literally be in the
famous words of their CEO above you
around you beneath you now of course it
almost goes without saying that there
will be immense hardware issues in
getting this all set up and running
smoothly billions of man hours worth of
problems to be solved for sure and
that's why companies it seems are
clamping up about how they're solving
these hardware issues the publishing of
methods has effectively stopped when
open Ai and others tell the hardware
industry about these issues they are
very vague and high level so as not to
reveal any of their dis distributed
systems tricks to be clear semi analysis
says these techniques are more important
than model architecture as both can be
thought of as compute efficiency here
then is the central claim from semi
analysis there is a camp that feels AI
capabilities have stagnated ever since
GPT 4's release I know many of you
watching will feel that this is
generally true but only because no one
has been able to massively increase the
amount of compute dedicated to a single
model the word only there is of course
an opinion rather than an established
fact some of course believe that no
amount of scaling will yield true
reasoning or intelligence I have my
thoughts but honestly I'm somewhat
agnostic I genuinely want to know how
these future models perform on my simple
bench I go into a ton of detail about
what I'm creating on my patreon which is
called AI insiders oh and also just a
couple of days ago I released this video
on that Epoch AI research that reminds
me actually there was one more thing
from that research that I wanted to
touch on in this video it came about
halfway through the 20,000 word report
and it's right here I don't know why I
picked out I just find it really quite
pant and interesting to see what these
beham moth companies will do because
basically what they pledged this is
Google Microsoft and Amazon to become
carbon neutral by 2030 now what do you
predict will happen if it turns out that
the scaling hypothesis is true and that
AI is immensely profitable and yet it
requires this immense power and that
will break these targets will they stick
to their honorable pledges well we know
what samman wants to do which is spend
in the order of trillions and finance
dozens of new chip factories this was
from a separate information report but
there was one quote that I found
interesting in relation to it samman
according to the CEO of tsmc which makes
most of these chips the power Nvidia and
everyone else he said samman was quote
too aggressive for me to believe
Remember by the way that pretty much all
of this comes down to that Taiwanese
company which is why by the way the
whole tech industry is so nervous about
China invading Taiwan anyway Sam wman is
according to the tsmc CEO too aggressive
for him to believe and maybe even these
125 billion data centers are also too
aggressive only time will tell it's
indubitable that a mountain has been
identified and that the AI industry
is trying to climb it whether they will
or indeed whether they're even heading
in the right direction only time will
tell thank you as ever so much for
watching all the way to the end I'm
super grateful and have a wonderful day